عمليه اطلاق نار اخرى في القدس المحتله
والمتهم بتنفيذها فتى يبلغ من العمر 13
عاما عمليه اسفرت عن اصابه مستوطنين
احدهما ضابط في الجيش بينما اصيب الفتى
بنيران مستوطن فنقل الى المستشفى تحت
حراسه مشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه هذه
العمليه
وفي ثلاثه ايام الماضيه وحدها في مدينه
القدس اربع شهداء وما زال الاحتلال يحرك
بخصوصا بني كثير حينما يقوم بتكريمها
القتله قطره قطره الفتره محمد علي في مخيم
شعفاط والسياسات التنكريه الاحتلاليه في
مدينه القدس
بعد العمليه اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال منزل
العائله في بلده سلوان واعتقلت والديه
وشقيقه كما عززت قواتها واستدعت مزيدا من
الوحدات الخاصه الى البلدات والاحياء
الفلسطينيه في القدس المحتله وذلك بعد ان
اعلنت عن رفع حاله التاهب الى الدرجه
القصوى
اجراءات قد تكون مقدمه لتصعيد محتمل يحمل
الجانب الفلسطيني مسؤوليه حدوثه وتداعياته
للجانب الاسرائيلي
الحكومه الاسرائيلي مسؤوليه الاحداث
القائمه ودعوه كامل الفصائل للحوار الوطني
الشامل من اجل مواجهه مرحله غايه في الدقه
والتحديات بالاضافه الى دعوه العالم
والاداره الامريكيه لاتخاذ موقف سيامه انه
انعدام العدل يعني استمرار عدم الاستقرار
وعدم تحقيق مطالب الشعب الفلسطيني سيعني
استمرار المواجهه وقعت هذه العمليه وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده وبعد ساعات على عمليه
اطلاق نار في حي نفي يعقوب الاستيطامي
اسفلت عن مقتل سبعه اسرائيليين عمليه عبرت
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه عن مخاوفها
من ان تشكل حافزا لشبان اخرين لا ينتمون
الى تنظيمات بعينها فيقدم على تنفيذ
عمليات مماثله ويصعب احباطها ولعل ابرز
المخاوف الاسرائيليه ان تنتقل المواجهه
الى مدينه القدس في ظل حكومه اقصى اليمين
المتطرف تلجا سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى تصعيد العمليات والاجراءات ضد
الفلسطينيين وهو ما قد يقود الى تفجر
الاوضاع لا سيما وان كل تصعيد اسرائيلي
يقابله تصعيد فلسطيني بل ومزيد
من الاصرار على المواجهه